[Music]
it's been brutal unpredictable and i've
got a feeling that there will be a few
more twists to come today and the next
few days will be absolutely critical in
deciding who will be the next prime
minister of this country there are five
candidates left in the race to become
the next conservative party leader and
by wednesday there will be just two left
standing
trust tax and trans policy have
dominated the race so far there'll be
another tv debate tonight and because
it's such an unpredictable race it does
feel like the briefings have been
particularly fierce on the show today
we'll try and work out who's got the
momentum to push on to the final two
we'll be joined in the studio by dominic
ramp who's endorsed russia sunak to be
the next prime minister suggesting his
colleague is someone who makes things
happen
the former conservative leader serene
duncan smith will be here to tell us why
he's backing liz truss
lee rowley is manning managing kemi
badernott's campaign the wild card who's
won some fans during this leadership
campaign
we'll also be talking to tracy nichols
the chief executive of the college of
paramedics about the pressure on
ambulance services as a heatwave hits
nick william of the train drivers union
aslef will join us from toll puddle
ahead of the train strikes later this
month and we'll also be finding out what
labour makes of the contest so far with
the shadow education minister bridget
phillipson
[Music]
hello and welcome to the final safety
ridge on sunday of the season before
parliament breaks for the summer next
week and i have to say since coming back
from maternity leave it has been an
absolute roller coaster exactly two
weeks ago teresa's coffee was in the
studio defending the prime minister
about what he knew when about
allegations over the behaviour of the
former deputy chief whip chris pincher
well since then boris johnson has
announced his resignation and we're now
in a full-blown leadership race
or we can introduce on that note our
first guest dominic raab has endorsed
sunak to be the next prime minister he's
backing his former cabinet colleague who
is currently the front-runner in the
campaign uh rishi soon as says inflation
needs to be brought down before taxes
can be cut he's also accused his rivals
of spreading fairy tales about the
economy dominic rob deputy prime
minister joins us now thank you very
much for being uh with us um before we
get on to the race i'm just keen to talk
about the heat wave quickly it's
something that so many of our viewers
can be thinking about whether you've got
kids at school whether you're
communicating to work how concerned
should we be and what preparations are
in place well i think being
prepared is the the best uh resilience
if you like i know that the nhs are
doing a whole load of contingency
planning that's actually their stock in
trade they're well prepared for that kit
malt house at the cabinet office is
making sure the other preparations are
in place obviously there's some common
sense practical advice that we're
talking about stay
hydrated stay out of the sun at the
hottest times sun cream and those sorts
of things but we'll uh uh we ought to
enjoy the sunshine and actually we ought
to be resilient enough through some of
the pressures it will place would it be
smart for some people to work from home
look that's for employers to uh to
consider him for people to decide i'm
not gonna start dictating things like
that but obviously we've got more
flexible working it's one of the things
after the pandemic lots of businesses
are doing um so that will also help with
this kind of thing and how about parents
as well who might be concerned about
their kids going into school and do you
think it would be fair enough for them
to keep them at home for a couple of
days i think i mean look we're coming to
the end of uh
the the school term anyway but i think
making sure uh young children um get the
education they need is really important
particularly after the pandemic um and
the schools are well placed to deal with
that okay uh right let's talk about the
leadership race shall we and also more
widely the political situation over the
last few weeks been extraordinary
um
obviously rishi sunak is your preferred
candidate but just to rewind a bit um
you know when other ministers were
resigning or telling boris johnson that
he needed to go it was reported that you
were loyal to the pm to the end is that
accurate yes i mean look i give my
council as deputy prime minister and as
a cabinet member privately um and but
but i did want to uh avoid a leadership
contest and i did want to support the
prime minister but he lost the support
of the parliamentary party and once that
happens i think you look forward uh and
we try and and actually the one thing
about our system is it will resolve this
relatively swiftly by first week of
september and you've got to look forward
and that's politics uh you say it's
relatively swiftly by the 5th of
september some would say that actually
it's still quite a long time that boris
johnson is still imposed
did you have any conversations about
potentially taking over as it can take a
pm
as you're obviously deaf to and pm no um
it was much discussed of course if it
had been ultimately necessary i i would
have been willing to do it but i think
it's the right thing and it's also what
we've done in the past when the prime
minister's had to step down to allow
them to continue until the new leader
was in place so it wasn't seriously
considered at any point then i think it
would have depended on effectively what
mps as a whole would have wanted but i
think once the pm made clear he would
step down i think the push
for an immediate
resignation and walking away from number
10 i think that went away how did you
find boris johnson in those weeks well
do you know what one of the things about
him is i think he's very magnanimous he
clearly was disappointed but got on with
the the process of making sure the
government is still stable looking at
what more we can do in the weeks
ahead to make sure that we consolidate
the
achievement and keep the delivery going
whether it's on the cost of living
particularly which people are concerned
about so i think he was focused on doing
the job i mean uh clearly a very
difficult time for him um i'm quite
interested because you obviously you
know you say that you were like loyal to
the prime minister to the end but you've
decided to back rishi sunak in the
context who many people in your party
believe was really the driving force
forcing him from office when he resigned
why
well they just don't accept that account
but the reason i'm supporting rishi
sunak and i said one thing about
leadership contest it forces you to look
at the future is that he is i think far
and away the best
place with the experience and the
caliber to see us through the cost of
living challenge i think he's the one
with a credible economic plan to get
inflation down if we can't do that we're
not going to leave people with the money
in their pockets from tax cuts or
anything else so controlling inflation
but then driving forward and he set out
some further ideas about boosting
through deregulation smarter regulation
the pharmaceutical sector the tech
sector the financial sector uh financial
services sector today i also um think
he's got the right values which is i
think uh what you're touching on i mean
i've known rishi since he first became a
member of parliament um the the values
that he grew up with of hard work family
entrepreneurialism i know the story i've
heard it privately let alone in the
course of these leadership uh debates
and hustings about how when his mum was
running the pharmacy he would help her
do the books he understands if you like
that pocketbook economics which i think
is so important at time the cost living
and thirdly and let's remember what this
is ultimately about in two years the
general election and the polling shows
he's far and away the strongest
candidate to beat kirsten on we'll
definitely dissect some of those things
uh later but just on
boris johnson loyalty uh question you
know others who did stand by boris
johnson have ended up rowing in behind
liz trust nadine doris for example jacob
rees-mogg who said that rishi sunex
showed disloyalty
according to the papers boris johnson
wants anybody but rishi sunak to be
prime minister did you talk to the prime
minister about your decision to back him
so of course there's a courtesy i want
to make sure the pm knew before
i've talked to him since i've not heard
any of those kind of things from him but
of course there'll be a circle of
advisors and people who want to back liz
will make these points i'm going to
adhere meticulously to reagan's 11th
commandment and not speak ill of my
fellow conservatives and actually what
might be any person in this context well
i
i mentioned it during the referendum of
trying to play the ball not the uh man
or the woman and i'm going to do it
again but look i think people want a
positive perspective and i think rishi
on those three critical things economic
plan uh values and
frankly electability ability to reach
out not just within the conservative
party but to the country whether it's
blue wall or red wall seats he's the guy
that can win at the end of the day i
think that's pretty important factor in
all of this well let's talk about the
economic policy
shall we you know richie sunic always
says that he is someone who believes in
low taxes but if we just look at his
record i think we should be able to show
um some of that on the screen now and
because he raised taxes this is the uk
tax changes for different chances as you
can see
along the bottom there
everything above the line is raising
taxes overall below the line is the tax
changes that would lessen the burden you
can see there that rishi sunac raised
taxes same amount in two years as gordon
brown did
in 10. he says he believes in low taxes
but we got to look at his record it
points to a bit of a different story
well i think the the the elephant in the
room is caused the pandemic and we had
the biggest economic contraction in 300
years and then all the pressures of
getting the nhs back on track um i don't
think anyone none of those other
chances had to deal with that and very
interestingly all of the other
conservative chancellors who've
commented uh have said that actually
he's the one with the credible economic
plan but we want to get taxes i
absolutely accept the pandemic is is
something that came along and you have
to respond to but there are choices
there too you can raise taxes you can
also cut spending and go back to
austerity which risky sunny said he
didn't want to do or you can look at
borrowing so there are political choices
here too well you can't borrow your way
out of an inflation crisis and if people
are suggesting that we should make cuts
to the nhs at a time not just of kovi
but with all of the other non-coded nhs
challenges they've got to spell out
where they're coming from what rishi has
done is say look we need to get
inflation under control he has cut
national insurance the biggest tax cut
in a decade for for payroll is 330
pounds for a typical worker but what
he's not going to do and it's important
to explain why is cut taxes when
actually you'll be taking we want to all
leave people with more money in their
pocket but if you cut taxes and then
inflation robs people of that money
because it's worthless or sees interest
rates go up so their mortgages are more
expensive then frankly it's a it's a
it's a false economy and i think rishi
is the one that is credibly stating
until we control inflation he's the only
one saying this we're not going to be
able to deliver those other things and
he's also the one that's talking about
the long-term plan to strengthen
investment by taking a different
approach regulatory-wise he's talked
about this today tech pharmaceuticals
financial services areas of great
comparative advantage to the uk economy
so from the immediate challenge to the
long-term prospectus i think he's the
one with the plan liz trust says that
actually cutting taxes leads to growth
she said in the telegraph this morning
that a continuity economic policy under
who she could be talking about there has
led to low growth for decades
liz can answer for her policies and her
record she was chief secretary of the
treasury um people can see where the
spending and head count in the civil
service went up or down that's for them
to work out but what i just say this is
the immediate challenge what people are
worried about right now what do you mean
about the civil service
well
it's not just uh rishi that is going to
be accountable for what he's done in the
face of a massive pandemic but liz has
done was chief secretary of the treasury
i mean did she cut taxes at that time
did spending go up or down during her
period as uh cst i think without without
criticizing her personally i think it's
right that everyone on their record is
is scrutinized so what is the record
well you can go and look it up but i
want to focus on what rishi is saying
and what we're uh and what his team uh
uh backing him uh have been attracted to
it is the idea that sensible
conservative economics means you get
inflation down if not any money that is
delivered to people in their bank
accounts through tax cuts will be robbed
again through inflation or interest
rates uh and mortgage payments going up
that that can't be right we've got to
get inflation down and then and of
course he's talked about uh come 2024 uh
pending off the basic rate of income tax
when it is sustainable um
other candidates are saying that they
believe some of the tax cuts they're
promising can be self-funding uh penny
morgan for example wants to halve the 80
on fuel on paper that would cost 13
billion pounds her team tells sunday
times it would actually be self-funding
because drivers would end up buying more
fuel i you know i'd like to see a
serious analysis of self-funding tax
cuts sometimes it can have that effect
if you're generating um
more business activity that's why for
example what rishi did with the super on
capital allowances encourages business
investment that can encourage greater
revenue but but i don't think those
alternative suggestions are particularly
credible and of course the big question
is what impact would it have on
inflation until we've got inflation down
any money that is handed out with one
hand will be taken back with the with
with the other and i think you can see
that when we had the debate uh on friday
night and rishi explained that uh people
understood that and you can see from all
the polling that people feel that he's
the one leveling with the country about
the challenges we face but also offering
a credible well thought through plan to
get through it you talk about the
polling and and i know that you're
referring to polling of the general
public but i just want to talk about
polling and party members because it
does feel like actually when it comes to
party members he's not the favourite
choice
uh is he i think we have a look at some
of uh the uh hugo poll for example so
this is the kind of most recent serious
uh weighted poll of um conservative
party members they were asked which of
the following candidates do you most
want to replace boris johnson this was
earlier this week
penny morden
way out in front of rishi sunak well i
think if you look in the con home had
some other polling today uh it is quite
fluid but the reason i'm pointing he
doesn't top that one either though does
it well actually it's very close but of
course uh i think the more people hear
uh from rishi and the more the choice is
presented i think the more compelling it
gets but ultimately this isn't just you
can't just make this final point it's
not just a question for uh conservative
mps or indeed conservative members it is
a question for the country and i think
conservative members who will make this
decision will be focused particularly
when we get to the last round on who is
best placed to win over voters whether
they remain or leave swing voters labor
voters or soft conservative voters in
the shires in the uh the working class
blue wall seats as well as the red wall
seats and ultimately it is very clear in
the jail jail polling uh jail partner
poland shows very clearly rishi sonak is
the only one that can win but it's not
general election is it is this is this
is about kind of things this is about
party members and actually if you look
at the hugo poll yeah every one of the
head-to-heads which you see like
effectively losers like steve baker told
me
this week that whoever goes up against
rishi sooner in the head-to-head will
win well i don't think that's right and
the reason being first of all it's very
fluid the members point secondly the
members are ultimately one of the
factors uh of the the consideration
would be who can actually win in two
years time at general election and there
the the the gap is clear only if she can
win the others are 10 12 points behind
so when you ask the country and this
ought to be an outward-looking
contest or at least perspective
they they see that rishi can win from
the north of the south leave seats
remain seats and that's what ultimately
this will be about and i'm very
confident members will focus on that in
the last round um now four of the five
candidates who are still in the race
have committed to doing the sky news
debate on tuesday night the one who
hasn't so far is rishi sunex so will he
commit to doing it i'll let the campaign
team give you uh an answer on that i
don't know what the schedule is but uh
look at what i think he would be very
confident going into uh all these
debates i think he uh sean uh in the
channel four debate i'm sure he will
again uh this evening but you accept the
importance of these debates because as
you have been saying as well you know
it's not just about the concept of party
members isn't it we're electing the
people are electing the next prime
minister oh look i don't think rishi's
shying away from that scrutiny i think
he's the the standout performer in these
debates of of the candidates that are
likely to win um so uh but look at i
don't know what the schedule is and i'll
let him uh and his team answer that do
you think whoever wins should call an
election to get their own mandate
there's a mandate for the conservative
party it's important we deliver on that
and we'll have an election in a couple
of years time i think the the country so
no basis i don't think the people i
think voters are going about their
ordinary business with the cost of
living challenges with the war in
ukraine with all the other things we're
dealing with i think they want a
government in place delivering for them
and that's what i'm sure we'll focus on
and so you don't see a problem in say
160 000 or whoever many conservative
members choosing the next prime minister
we had this debate every time it wasn't
a problem when gordon brown took over it
wasn't a problem um when uh
theresa may uh took over and and it
won't be a problem uh in september okay
finally who are actually nearly finally
on finally on the uh leadership question
um who do you think is for succeeding
his biggest rival
i don't want to get into that
because
look they they're all good candidates i
said i'd adhere to reagan's 11th
commandment i think one of the things
we've shown actually in this contest is
the breadth of talent in the
conservative party uh you've got
entrepreneurs you've got people with
armed forces experience and i'm very
proud that we've got a slate of
candidates diverse in all sorts of
different ways not just background but
also professional and others now very
finely because i promised myself that
when i next interviewed you i am going
to ask you about this so i am going to
um
a few weeks ago you had a very lively
prime minister's question session with
angela rainer and right at the end
you seem to be giving a wink i think we
should be able to show wig i'm gonna
have to go now i've got a train to catch
[Applause]
she talks about working people she talks
about working people
[Applause]
what is going on there who were you
winking at i was winking at ian murray
who was by angie ray now by the way i've
got a sanji reigns great value in all of
these uh she's so so lively i mean it's
a quite a contrast with kier um but so
why were you ringing ian murray he and
murray
i find this to just ask more questions
well at pmq's you have these subplots
going on and he was sort of praying at
me uh from uh uh by angie's side and uh
um uh i was winking at him uh but not
least because he was talking about i
think there was something uh that was
said about uh angela rayner standing in
a leadership contest against kyr and he
said what sort i think i heard him say
something like what's wrong with that um
so anyway uh it's all part of the cut
and thrust there you go uh thank you
very much glad that we did clear that up
so there you go dominic rav winking at
air murray north angela rainey thank you
very much for being on the program today
uh dominic
uh there
oh well in this contest of course um
everyone gets a vote to decide who they
want to go to the uh final two and our
next guest syrian duke and smith the
former conservative party leader has
decided to back liz truss he says that
she's right on the economy and has
proved herself on the world stage or
writing in the telegraph this week he
said that only list trusts understands
that getting the burden of costs down
while helping the poorest will be the
only way to deliver for the british
people although she's the
longest-serving cabinet minister in the
running at liz truster they've been
surprised to see the level of support
for some other candidates merging uh we
can uh talk now to sit in duncan smith
shall we who knows all too well what
it's like to win and the support of your
party in a leadership contest thank you
very much for being
with us and i just want to react firstly
to a few things that dominic raab was
saying
he was talking about tax cutting
and
spending squeezers and saying that yes
you can judge everyone on their record
shouldn't we be judging this trust on
her record as well
yeah of course you have to judge jerry
on their record in fact that's one of
the things i've been maintaining that we
can't have anybody rise without trace we
do need to know after all most of the
main candidates in this debate have all
been in government for the better part
of two and a half years so it's very
important to know what their record says
about them when they have the power to
do things and i think that's very
important liz's is on record you know
she's done these phenomenal trade deals
particularly with australia by the way
which wasn't a follow-on trade deal and
also the trans-pacific partnership which
opens us into the far east which is
really delivering brexit and the other
one of course she's stood up at ukraine
she's been very very strong about our
involvement support for ukraine
which is a really really vital issue and
also now northern ireland where she's
helping resolve that so her record is
strong but if you come to the issue
which you said was taxation there is a
genuine debate to be had here in the
party about this
because i think the government and the
treasury through a sort of peculiar
orthodoxy is bound on the wrong course
which could seriously damage us over the
next two years looking at this though
because obviously you know tax cuts it's
one part of the debate and fiscal
responsibility i guess is part of it um
if you look what liz trust has promised
to do to reverse the rise in national
insurance to cancel the rise in
corporation tax act screen levies on
energy bills allowing families to share
their tax allowance
according to the ft that will cost over
30 billion pounds a year how's that
gonna be funded yeah she's talking about
a whole series of potential taxes that
you can deal with which will help first
of all let's face what the problem is
the problem is
it's
something to do the fact that outside
there's uh demand is outstrip supply
post the pandemic the
remarkable lockdown we've got an
inflationary spiral going on now we've
got the war in ukraine that's maybe even
worse with regards to energy but here in
the uk
we do have to bear some of the blame for
the fact that we have inflation rising
on top of all of that and that's down to
the bank of england and the treasury's
failure over i think uh monetary policy
so first of all over a year ago well
this is important uh the bank
actually kept on printing huge sums of
money which inflated the economy as well
as keeping interest rates low now it was
the treasury that signed off on that
money printing the chancellor no less
and so before they say oh it's
independent treasury has the right to
say no to the money printing bit and
they didn't just because that has fueled
inflation so inflation is now
domestically a problem we have to deal
with that who are you talking about
signing off on on this well the
chancellor signed off on the uh on the
extra money that was printed
of course because the the treasury has
the right to say no
between them and the bank frankly i
think they got that one wrong then the
second point is okay inflation is a big
problem because it takes away people's
earnings and their savings
and this is where liz is right about
this which is you now need to have to
look at two things though we have to get
inflation down and at last the bank is
raising interest rates and that should
begin to bring this under control but at
the same time if you end up
by trying to target that so exclusively
that you end up with the highest tax
rate that we've had since the 1940s you
will crush the economy at the same time
now at the same time just to come in
because many people would argue that
actually if you're looking at tax cuts
and that does have an inflationary not
necessarily just just just to continue
uh wishes who next in the debate
borrowing your way out of inflation is a
fairy tale uh paul johnson of the ifs
saying that it is correct that tax cuts
funded by borrowing could potentially
increase inflation it may result he says
in the bank of england increasing
interest rates a little bit further the
opposite of what
we would want to happen and a little bit
faster than the otherwise would have
done and that's confusing two things
first of all no one's talking about uh
tax cuts aided by boring here's the
problem well listen let me get to the
root of this the problem right now we
face is that the treasury is bound on
the wrong course why is that because if
you have the tax rates at the rate they
are now
with more to come
corporation tax you are going to bring
our economy into recession that's what's
forecast now if we go into recession
whilst we have high inflation that's
stagflation which means it's like an
aircraft so how is how is transponding
for tax cuts very important so
then if you end up in a recession what
happens is your revenues from your tax
receipts of fall what happens then you
increase your borrowing because you
can't meet your
commitments so now actually the plan
they got will actually increase
borrowing not reduce it at all make it
even worse lowering tax key taxes
absolute taxes that bring down
that risk and therefore allow the
economy to grow and the economy growing
is critical to get us through this in
the next 12 months that means we won't
need to borrow more money to fund those
taxes what we're going to do right now
is borrow more money because we'll go
into recession and we will not be able
to meet our existing commitment so the
30 billion tax cuts
just talk to me about the funding for
that she's talked about the range of
what we can do that covers all of the 30
billion but if you look carefully
well i'm going to tell you the treasury
housing the treasury has headroom the
government right now in the last two
years their receipts exceeded their
forecasts but wait a minute but the 30
billion head room is under question
because of the poorer outlook of the
economy that you've just been talking no
no we've actually seen already better
growth than we thought was going to
happen earlier in the year that will
fall away but the key point all the
independent economists will tell you
this you have headroom two points the
receipts that came in over the last two
years have far exceeded anything that
was forecast by about 180 billion you
have an extra 30 billion but you also
have something else which is very
important you have the flexibility
within all this because right now even
now the government is inflating away one
large section of their debt that debt is
the index-linked debt which because of
inflation they're getting and the third
area they're getting they already have a
windfall tax because the windfall tax on
things like the cost of the press uh of
the tax they're getting on petrol on vat
these things are all coming in faster
and harder so their revenues have
increased dramatically we're saying put
some of that back into reducing the
burden on people so they don't suffer as
they're going to suffer if we head into
recession so if things have been better
than predicted should rishi sooner get a
bit of credit for that what rishi sooner
should do is use the money because this
is down to the accidents of inflation so
the key point here is the treasury is
wrong if you crush both
growth in the economy and high high
interest rates you will destroy the
outcomes for lots of people we need to
get that right growth is critical and
tax reduction key tax reduction will
actually help aid growth and that's
vital um you mentioned at the beginning
of the interview about the importance of
people who have been tested
and you um perhaps said to me earlier
this week as well you did say to me
earlier this week that you're not sure
what penny maldon has done for the last
few years
what did you mean by that i just said
that everybody's record should be fully
open and examined about your
achievements
my point is we've had two and a half
years post brexit where everybody bar
tom tugginhat i think is in government
everybody needs to be judged on what
they've achieved and that's the whole
campaign
and liz trust is open uh rishi sunak's
open kemi is open the one person i
personally don't know what her big
achievements are is penny i don't have
any problem with her
issues at all but for me it's about
the key thing is we're not electing a
leader of the conservative party that
has two years to build their
their reputation we are electing someone
who will be prime minister on day one so
you need to know when they had power and
authority in government what did they do
with it what did they get what did they
achieve what were their main beliefs
what did they drive through what tough
decisions did they have to take that
actually they had to sometimes go
against their civil servants to get
these things done i mean i ran a
department for six years work seven days
a week i know what it's like to make
tough decisions so the key thing is i
want to know
where are these tough decisions from all
of them it's not aimed at her it's all
of us so all the candidates need to be
completely open about that and argue i
know what it's like to take tough
decisions because this is what i did
what are the big things and you're
concerned that penny morden well of all
the candidates of iowa stan look at the
one i don't know enough about what she's
actually done i know what the others
have done so i want to know what does
she believe her big achievements are and
where was she actually fighting for
things how many hours did she spend
working at this where did she face those
tough decisions you know were you
questions about lord frost's um
intervention where he's sorry lord frost
uh who said that he um effectively uh
was what she went missing when she was
portrayed minister in his words
well that's his view i don't know i've
not worked with her so all i'm saying is
this just leads the whole point we need
to know what what actually does she
believe about it
because obviously he and others don't
think so so i want to know what is your
real key area to be able to say i can
land two feet in downing street and
govern from day one because
i know what it's like to take tough
decisions and that's the key element for
me for choice um a recent uh concept of
home poll um not weighted we should say
but still useful um has said that kevin
badenock appears to be
their choice for who should be the next
leader of the conservative party you can
see there she's um
well quite quite sizably ahead of uh liz
trust there do you think that she could
end up being on the final two the
candidate of the right well i'd have no
problem with uh kemi and liz being on
the final two i think the members would
get just the two that they want to fight
and uh i think liz will will win because
of a greater experience because she's
gonna be wrong i like kemi a lot i think
she's a very good candidate uh but i
think liz is the one that has the
greatest depth of experience and and
let's face it whatever else in this uh
kind of uh fashion show candidates the
truth is only one thing matters are you
going to be the person capable on the
day one that you stop in downing street
two feet on the ground governing from
that moment with the character and the
grit to be able to do unpopular things
and get them done first and i think
that's where liz scores just very
finally i want to ask you about the
front page of the observer which is
about alex sharma who's been obviously
doing a lot of work with the government
on the climate change agenda he says
that he could quit his role
if they push some of the candidates
obviously talking about scrapping the
commitment to net zero he says he could
quit if that happens
well i'm sorry he he feels that actually
i thought in the case of the debates the
key thing is we face a number one crisis
which is cost of living inflation where
fuel at the pumps etc is very high
there are moments when sometimes even if
you want to achieve something and
lizard said she does still want to
achieve and at zero
every now and then sometimes you have to
say well for the moment we have to just
put that slightly on the back burner
whilst we make sure people don't suffer
and we have the capacity to reduce the
burden on them by getting rid of some of
these green levees you can come back to
that process when we get through this
but for the moment if you ask anybody
out there what their key problem is they
need to get to work in the morning they
need to be able to afford to buy their
food they want to be able to heat their
homes come the winter these things mean
we need to do more gas and at the same
time relieve people of those extra
levies because this is what really
matters to here and now yes we want to
get to net zero but we need to do in a
way that we don't crush the public while
we're doing it and make sure that the
things we do are absolutely right but
this is talked about modular reactors
more emphasis on gas as a transitional
fuel after all we sit on an island of
gas and oil we should be using the gas
and we might be able to help europe as
well get off their
addiction to russian oil and gas if we
weren't pumping it to them okay thank
you very much for being on the program
this morning duncan smith uh there
uh now before the conservative party
leadership has started the name kami
badanok was perhaps rarely suggested as
someone likely to replace boris johnson
as prime minister and yet the staff from
walden mp is proving her popularity
among party members she certainly
secured some high profile backers
including michael gove and she hasn't
shied away from stepping into the
culture wars questioning her rival penny
mortens account of her position when she
was minister for women and equalities
we can now talk to our next guest who is
lee rowley her campaign uh manager thank
you very much for being uh with us on
the programme today
i think it is fair to say that you know
most of our viewers may not have heard
the name came in bajanak before this
contest began
prime minister isn't an entry-level job
what was the most senior job that she
held in
held in government so until last week
she was a minister of state in the local
government department she's held a
number of jobs a number of different
departments including treasury she's had
the equalities brief she's done some big
jobs admittedly not in cabinet but big
jobs over the last three years and she's
done them well it's not just about the
job you have it's about what you do with
it and the one thing kemi has done over
the last three years taking on
particularly the equalities brief for
example demonstrates she's willing to
take on people who don't necessarily
agree with her she's willing to stake
clear views and she's willing to do so
at the same time though
this isn't an audition for opposition
leader right the person who wins this is
going to be the next prime minister and
are there any concerns that you have
about whether someone who's most the
highest level of experience they've had
as a minister of state is really ready
to get the keys of downing street if i
had concerns i wouldn't be here sophie
this morning i mean i if you look at
what kemi has done over three years
she's had some big jobs in government
she's taking on some difficult briefs
she's done some big things with them
some things which are challenging but in
terms of equalities there's a very very
sensitive debate around that around what
you do with with against racism how you
make sure that discrimination isn't
around she went and brought forward the
uh the commission on on racial disparity
she's actually trying to get the root
causes of some of those issues against a
huge amount of opposition but if you
look at kenny compared to say david
cameron zero ministerial uh experience
but he was opposition leader this is the
difference
he was elected to the position he had
not spent a day in ministerial office
before he became prime minister in 2017
he'd not taken a single decision as a
minister tony blair had not taken a
single
serial debate absolutely he's done that
i accept that and i also accept that
there is perhaps some you know sexism in
the way that we talk about a woman
compared to the experience of
david cameron george osborne tony blair
but the question is the fact that this
is literally going into the job of prime
minister absolutely and as i say lots of
ministerial experience
has more ministerial experience than
some of the people who by common consent
have been very big figures within our
political system over the past 20 years
and i think the public are looking for
something different so if you are
looking for something different what
chemi offers is both the ability to
change the ability to say actually we've
done some things lots of things well
over the last 12 years but we need to do
something different now she wants to
slim some experience what specifically
would she cut well she's going to set
some more out of that in the coming in
the coming days but she's already talked
about how we need to look at university
courses because there are some
university courses which perhaps don't
require public subsidy she's talked
about 300 billion pounds worth of public
money taxpayer subsidy which is which is
spent every year by the government in
procuring services she wants to look at
doing that better and she also wants to
look all across
what the official chestnut that everyone
talks about the reason why people talk
about it and it doesn't get delivered is
because you don't go to the root causes
of the issues i have seen far too much
government by press release when i've
both been a minister and when i've been
an mp and the difference between kemi
and what's happened before under all
parties is that kenny is actually saying
we need to go to the root cause of an
issue work out what the problem is and
then try and come forward with some
she's obviously talked a lot about the
trans debate and penny morden's a
position on trans right when she was a
qualities minister and kevin bateman
told the sunday times today i'm not
going to call her a liar i think it's
very possible she genuinely did not
understand what she was signing off
i'm not sure what's worse being called a
lion or liar or saying you didn't
understand it well what kenny is saying
is this is a very and if you go further
down the sunday times article kevin's
saying this is a very very difficult
issue with some very very entrenched
views on both sides it needs to be
handled sensitively penny has a set of
questions to answer she i don't think
she really answered those particularly
well in debate on sunday on friday we'll
see whether she does tonight because
either
penny
did agree with self id and is now saying
that she didn't question why or penny
didn't agree with self-id but it looks
as though the government decided to go
ahead with the the civil service and the
government and the department decided to
do it anyway question how did she let
that happen one of those two questions
that he's answering by penny and i look
forward to her doing so later and
baroness williams who worked in the
department at the time has hit out today
about what she describes as factually
incorrect representations put forward by
leadership candidates and she said that
she's shocked to see such incorrect
briefings do you think that this is
really getting into the into the realms
of mudslinging here well penny just
needs to clear up the point either she
didn't agree with self-id
at the time and therefore she allowed
the civil service to do something else
question was that the right thing for a
minister to do or she did agree with
self id and now she's saying she didn't
she can clear it up today if she wants
to well she well she i'm she will be
speaking today obviously and but it does
feel let's move on to other
uh issues shall we there's been a lot on
trans rights so far as well um i want to
talk a little bit about um kevin
bateman's position in the race because
it felt like you know she was kind of a
big outsider she's obviously
outperformed many people's expectations
conservative home uh pole out today
which i think we can have another look
at
worth saying that this is unweighted and
so you know there are questions about
that but kemi beijing there um published
july the 14th clearly out in front
um
do you think that she could make the
final team
yeah i do we're here to make the final
two kemi is absolutely in it to win i
mean this leadership campaign i think is
now nine or ten days old and kemi
decided to run last week talking to a
group of us because she thinks she's got
something to say and she wants to try
and change the country and what i think
this is showing and as you say it's a
snapshot but i think it's an important
snapshot it's saying that members of the
conservative party want kemi in the
final two and want that debate to happen
over the next six weeks about where the
party is going but more importantly
where the country needs to go i mean
sierra lebron another candidate of the
right of the party was eliminated on
thursday
she backlist trusts
were you disappointed not to get her
support
well we're fighting for every every
every every colleague support i'll be on
the phones later talking to colleagues
to try and convince people that kemi is
the right person and we're getting some
really good feedback on the specifically
owned swellers as well as a friend she's
a friend of kemi's people have to make
their own decisions i mean you can't you
can't make half a decision suella's made
the decision she's written about that
today but i disagree with her and i
disagree that's why i didn't join her
campaign in the first place so i didn't
absolutely agree with some of the things
she was saying but that's part of the
debate and it's why i'm absolutely
committed to getting kevin into the
final two as much as i can do and then
kenny can make her case to the members
and then times the british people as
prime minister
i'm quite intrigued about where kemmie
boyd badenock's support could go if she
is knocked out i know that you're going
to say we're fighting to the final two
we wanted to get to the next prime
minister but there is obviously a chance
that she is eliminated in one of the
earlier rounds you know some would like
to see her throw her weight behind liz
trust we've heard lord frost say that
for example
but there are rumors that actually she
may be more likely to roll in behind
russia's cenac well you're absolutely
right i'm going to say that kemi is in
it's a winner because she is because
we said to kemi when a group of us when
kemi was saying that she thought she was
thinking about doing this we said if
you're going to do it do it to win and
we'll back you and that's why i'm here
today and it's why i've been trying to
help on the campaign for the last 10
days she is really serious about this
there is so many issues in our country
we've got to change it and my personal
view is we've got to change it with a
fresh start the um i guess one of the
conspiracies doing the random
westminster is michael gove her perhaps
most high-profile backer
is doing this as a way to help rishi
sunak into number 10 but perhaps without
getting his fingerprints on it is it
black ops there for michael gove you
think
i just don't know where some of this
stuff comes from i've been an mp for
five years this place just goes round
and round and round in some very strange
places sometimes kemi is on it to win
she wants to be prime minister she's
looking forward to changing the country
and that's why i'm backing it i really
hope she has the opportunity to do that
okay thank you very much uh lee rowley
there the campaign manager for
kemi fadenock
quick reminder that we are going to have
a special program coming up this week
because sky news very excitingly is
going to be broadcasting a live tv
debate with those who want to be the
next leader of the conservative party
and of course most importantly the
country's next prime minister so the
debate will be hosted by our very own
okay burly it's going to be taking place
on tuesday at 8 00 pm so you don't want
to miss that k burley is going to be
hosting the battle for number 10 one of
those leadership debates that can have
such
a key
impact on these contests
now this week we're being warned not to
travel or in fact to go outside too much
because of the heat lots of people i
know are going to be working out what to
do because a red warning has been
declared across england with a met
office warning of the possibility of
seeing temperatures of up to 40 degrees
on monday and tuesday well the heatwave
is bound to put some extra pressure on
the nhs and the ambulance services in
england are already at the highest alert
level because of extremely high demand
we can talk now to our next guest tracy
nichols the chief executive officer of
the college of paramedics thank you so
much for being with us um
temperatures could hit 40 degrees this
week the new health secretaries asked
ambulance crews to work more hours on
monday and tuesday
what are we expecting to see
um i think
sophie will will see
the normal demand that we're seeing sort
of running along currently which which
your viewers will be will be well versed
with but we could see uh people who are
particularly who are vulnerable young
people um elderly frail people people
living with dementia who
really do suffer this this isn't like a
a lovely hot day where we can put a bit
of sunscreen on and go out and enjoy you
know a swim and a meal outside this is
serious heat
that could actually ultimately end in
people's death because it is so
ferocious and we're just not set up for
that sort of heat in this country
what would your advice be to people who
are concerned about you know how to keep
themselves and their families safe and
not too hot over the next few days
without sounding patronizing i think it
really is about taking sensible
precautions of course you know we love a
bit of warm weather but this is
something else so
try and stay in in the hottest part of
the day between about 11 and 4
because the heat is seeming to peak
later in the afternoon stay hydrated and
not with alcohol
really put sunscreen on even if you're
fully covered put sunscreen on wear a
hat and please check on those people who
are vulnerable and and that includes
people you know a homeless
community who who may just be transient
um walking along the streets or or
trying to stay cool you know think about
those people people living with dementia
may not understand that sitting out in
the sun they may forget how long they've
sat out there for us to really really
pay attention to uh to vulnerable people
during this time
and what contingency plans do the
ambulance trusts have
in place for the next few days so you
obviously we know that this is a service
already under pressure and there could
be increased demand couldn't then
incident plans if you like but you know
we're already running a really stretched
situation within the ambulance sector
but as uh the secretary of state for uh
health and social care announced there
is more money for call handlers which
will be
really welcome um i i don't know how
that money will translate into hours um
because it's it's quite late in the day
quite honestly but um it's really
welcome the ambulance sector will have
its contingency plans in place emergency
planning uh exercises are run regularly
within the ambulance sector so um the
the crews the uh call handlers and the
army of community first responders and
community teams will be out over the
next two days
um of course it comes at a time when
ambulance services are already under
serious pressure i just want to have a
look now at the waiting times for last
month so 1 in 10 people waited two hours
for an ambulance and for serious uh
conditions category two things like
heart attacks like strokes the average
waiting time was over 50 minutes over 50
minutes for a heart attack i mean is
there a crisis
it's
it's difficult not to call it a crisis
sophie but it's it's been a stealth
crisis um and and i think you know
everyone who works in emergency care
knows that they will just put their
heads down and just keep plowing through
and keep dealing with whatever comes
through
the call handlers or through the
emergency department doors and they'll
just keep going um so it's not that
people aren't going to turn up it's just
that the system
is is not enabling paramedics
emergency department staff to do exactly
what they want to do which is look after
everybody
the west midlands ambulance director
mark dougherty gave an interview
recently where he said the 999 service
in his region would tip over in his
words in august when it might be
completely unable to respond to even the
most critical cases is this a serious
concern
it is this this will be based on
modelling that the ambulance services do
regularly and probably from mark's
perspective that is when his modelling
shows him that
maybe through covered sickness absence
maybe through annual leave
through predicted demand that will put a
really enormous strain on on the west
midlands ambulance service um and and i
think what he's doing is sending the
flare up to say we don't do something
now um that you know that will realize
into something much more than a risk it
will be a reality
and i just want to work out what that
actually means as you say you know cover
cases are on the rise that has an impact
of course on absence too
does that basically mean that if you
call an ambulance and you need one you
might not get one
yeah and and i think we have to say that
for for many people who call for the
ambulance service it is absolutely
life-threatening um time critical and
and is very much an emergency i think
where people may not get one is where
their um illness or injuries is less
serious than a heart attack or a stroke
um and they they may be told that an
ambulance just isn't available and
people will have to find their own way
to to hospital that's the that's the
reality that we're in central and what
kind of cases are we talking about is it
you know broken legs what's the what
what kind of cases do you mean
it may be something like um abdominal
pains it may be um
headache uh where where people are still
conscious it may be long-term problems
the ambulance service do get a lot of
long-term problems and that are called
through where someone's had back pain
for two to three weeks that can't be
resolved
so it be cause of much less serious
nature they'll be absolutely stringently
triaged by those superb clinicians in
the control rooms um and and people will
they'll have that discussion with them
about a clinically appropriate response
are you concerned that at a time where
we do have this acute pressure on the
nhs and on ambulances in particular
we've also got a leadership contest
going on and we've got a government that
of course is still functioning but may
not be pushing through
any
new legislation or anything particularly
reforming as there will be a change of
prime minister in september
i i think my my view and the view of the
college sophie is that um you know i
know the leadership contest is necessary
we really need to see leadership in
action now this crisis is now it was
yesterday it was the day before
yesterday it will be tomorrow so we need
someone to lean in and support this
whole system and do a shared clinical
risk and decision making process across
the whole system the ambulance service
is just a manifestation of a whole
system issue it's just a very visible
sign for the public
we've of course seen
many of the candidates talking about tax
cuts and the rise in national insurance
that we saw earlier this year was billed
as a health and social care levy and we
know that at least two candidates wants
to
reverse that are you concerned what it
might mean for funding for the nhs
i think so i mean in real terms we we
haven't really had uh a vast amount of
funding um through the last 10 to 12
years um there was a deficit in the
workforce and
my goodness do we need good workforce
planning um to come out of
of this
we've never been in a pandemic before
and there is this huge backlog there is
this huge demand for services and we
need to model through that and then the
transition into
whatever normal looks like after this
but but certainly that the funding is
absolutely critical and i think um
someone had called for ambulances and
ambulance services to be made critical
assets and i think that's that's
probably something for discussion
okay thank you so much really
interesting to talk to you and about
some of those pressures
on such an important service as well
all rail workers are to stage a fresh
nationwide strike in the dispute over
pay jobs and conditions they're
threatening travel chaos at the height
of the summer holidays train drivers at
eight rail companies will walk out on
saturday the 30th of july marking the
first coordinated industrial action by
them since 1995 and of course it comes
after the rmt union which presents uh
represents other trained staff saying
that it will strike on wednesday the
27th of july and also over two days in
august well we can talk now to our next
guest mick whelan
who is the general secretary of azlev
joins us now from toll poddle in dorset
uh every year there's a festival to mark
the torpor martyrs who of course paved
the way for the trade union uh movement
thank you very much for being on the
programme and just talk us through what
strike action you're planning and the
impact that it could have on commuters
and people who need to use the trains
well quite obviously when train drivers
don't uh come to work trains don't run
so there'll be virtually no services in
those areas and that saddens us we'd
much rather be talking to people find a
way out of this but unfortunately no
one's coming to table
what is the strike about what pay rise
are you looking for
we haven't put an exact figure on it but
most people don't understand that nobody
in railway industries had to pay rise
for three years
so in two years of pandemic
we were key workers people were
approaching us we were getting other key
workers to work we're moving food and
medicine around the country
and when rpi was a lot lower
the pressure wasn't so much on but now
we're in year three and the cost of
doing crisis is hitting all workers and
we're not seeing just train drivers but
we've seen people cwu the post we're
seeing barristers we've seen all
sections now saying enough is enough
you say you don't want to put an exact
figure on the pay rise that you're
looking for and inflation of course is
around 9.1
are you looking for a pay rise to match
and keep pace with inflation
we'd like that standing still isn't
great standing still is standing still
and of course we wouldn't even be
standing still because we're not looking
retrospectively for the pay rises we
didn't get in the previous two years
we're saying this year everybody
deserves pay rise
but you won't put any figure on on what
that would be
well it's incredibly difficult for us
because as you know we're we're a
fraction of three so there's eight
companies by the time we finish the
probably 13 and they've all got
different terms conditions they all work
differently geographically and they've
all got different needs and you know we
don't work for the government we don't
work for the dft we don't work for the
treasury we work for arriva and
tintaglia and all of these private
companies and they've all been making
profits throughout the pandemic and
they're making profits now and it seems
council intuitive to us that they're
paying their shareholders and taking
money out of the uk to fund state
railways elsewhere while we can't get
pay rise internally
what's the current median salary for a
train driver
roughly about 59 000 pounds
because i guess for a lot of our viewers
they might think that is actually
already quite a lot of money
and
probably for a lot of people is and i
look at other workers i think they
should have what we have but every time
i ask the question if we don't get it
when you give 22 to the nurses will you
give it to the fire brigades to bring
them up and it brings other public
sector workers and it's not an
exhaustive list because so many people
deserve a proper living and a proper pay
rise you know it goes very very quiet so
we don't enter into this politics of
envy uh debate for us it's about
everybody who's entitled to pay rise
everybody should be on the standard that
we have
but do you think that some if you were
talking about prioritizing do you think
that people on lower incomes should be
prioritized for pay rises
yes and in the public sector that's down
to the government
we are actually still in the private
sector there may be legislation coming
for great british railways and may come
back in-house but at this moment in time
what's actually happened is slightly
duplicitous the
companies have done a deal with the
government not to offer us more than two
percent
we go to the company say that's not
enough the companies say well we can't
offer any more than government one
lettuce we go to the government they say
you've got to talk to the employers so
with this wonderful catch-22 situation
where they've done a deal um actually
smashing free collective bargaining i
mean it may even be illegal
and put us into this place where they
don't play sales today
i just want to talk to you about the
labour party uh if i may at your agm in
may um asla voted to remain affiliated
to the labour party but you noted that
there is a measure of disquiet with the
direction of the party
what exactly did you mean by that
i think there's a lot of traditionalists
who would like to see occasionally
labour stand up stand with workers more
regularly
we do believe it's the best game in town
for working people in the uk but we have
to put the offer out there we have to
show that we're different and we have to
show that we have the plans for the
recovery for the future and for that
just green transitions that should
create those high-paying quality jobs
that people need so do you think that
labour
frankly aren't doing enough to show
they're on the same side as working
people
i see an awful lot of work that it's
done behind the scenes so i do i've seen
that there is a mess amount being done i
just think zac occasionally was
communicating more
okay thank you very much indeed uh mick
wheeling there uh of uh azliv thank you
for coming on the program today
thank you
well this week's the kiss dahmer
described the conservative leadership
race as a travelling circus he also
criticized the candidates for promising
billions of pounds of unfunded tax cuts
labour's chosen to focus on tax cuts of
a different kind with a pledge to get
rid of the charitable status held by
some private schools and then reinvest
that money in state education well the
shadow education secretary bridget
phillipson uh joins us now thank you for
being with us um i just want to start
off by talking about the heatwave and
it's something that so many of our
viewers are going to be really concerned
about and the government is keen to keep
schools open we spoke to dominic
rahabelia on the program who said it's
important that children don't miss
school what's your position on this
would you support schools that do decide
to close and who
i think head teachers are usually the
best people to decide what's right in
the particular circumstances
of their school and you know closing
school should be a last resort of course
it should be i think what we've seen
however over the last 12 years is a
failure to get our schools into the best
possible state to deal with these kinds
of problems that applies when you have
very hot weather but also applies where
you have very cold weather and we've got
a crumbling schools estate in the
government that's failed to invest over
the last 12 years in making sure that
our schools are fit for the future a lot
of parents will be you know facing the
decision about whether to send their
children into school on you know monday
or tuesday particularly wednesday and
when the heat is so high and would you
support parents who decide to keep their
children off school on those days i'm
sure that head teachers will be doing
everything they possibly can to make
sure that their schools kept as cool as
possible that children are kept out of
the hot sun and are kept indoors as much
as possible i think children have missed
out quite a lot already in terms of
their education and it's right for them
to be there trust her teacher basically
they will always act in the best
interests of the children in the school
um i we just spoke to mcwhelan a moment
ago who of course is the head of the
azlev union one of a number of unions
who are going on strike do you back the
train driver strikes
we don't want the strikes to go ahead we
didn't last time and i would certainly
want further strikes to be avoided
because whenever you get to a position
where you have a strike that represents
a failure of all of the parties to reach
an agreed position what we saw with the
transport secretary of course is that he
refused consistently to get around the
table to try and find a way through it
because this is about you know cost of
living about the rising pressures that
workers are facing and also about safety
on our railways i mean whether there's
any question now given the chaos that
we're seeing in government about the
transport sector or whoever that might
be in a couple of weeks doing the right
thing and being responsible in terms of
getting around the table i think that
remains to be seen it's interesting i've
spoken to quite a lot of union leaders
over the last few weeks and it's a
pretty consistent message about labour
they're frustrated effectively their
labor isn't doing more to support them
in strong action they say that labour
needs to demonstrate that it's a party
that's on the side of working people can
you understand that frustration
i understand the pressures that working
families and workers across a range of
different parts of our economy are
feeling right now we know that wages
have been stagnant for many many years
we know that everything is more
expensive and that that means really
hard times for people that do incredibly
important jobs whether that's our
teachers staff on the railways i mean i
think what the trade unions would
recognize is that from government labour
had a really strong record of making
sure that we did support all of our
staff in those key industries and that's
what we do again um you mentioned
teachers there who of course have seen
you know pace squeeze for many years now
with austerity as well
teachers are considering strike action
would you support them in that well i
really hope it doesn't come to that as i
understand it um the review body will be
presenting to ministers what the what
their recommendations are i'm not going
to cut across that process but i think
as you say when you look at the real
terms pay cuts that teachers have had
over the last 12 years the pressure that
they're under the fact they've worked so
hard during the pandemic and have not
been recognized by the government i
think it's also important however to
mention school support staff who have
had
you know a really difficult time are so
important to our children getting the
support that they need in school and of
course one of the leadership candidates
was incredibly dismissive talked about
superfluous support stuff i don't know
what plan she's living on if she thinks
we've got too many staff in our school
supporting children well kemi badanok
was very dismissive of our school
support staff but right across you know
nadeem sahar with a new chancellor the
former education secretary he's been
saying we should have 20 cuts across
government departments i think that
extends to education i think that he was
clarifying that the 20 cut was to civil
servants not of course not the spending
on all government departments well that
has a massive impact i mean who does he
think will be responsible for delivering
on government priorities at the moment
for example
i'm inundated with people who can't get
a passport to go on holiday who does he
think is responsible for making sure
that people across the country can get a
passport and can get a well-deserved
break we were talking about teachers pay
and there are reports that the body that
you're talking about are going to
recommend a 5 pay rise which of course
would end up being another real terms
pay cut if you look at inflation as well
and how much would a labor government
increase teachers pay by well let's wait
and see what they say we don't know that
yet i'm not going to put a figure on
that and i'm not going to cut across
that negotiating process
the level of pay and the figure that you
put on it is incredibly important but i
know from speaking to teachers and
support staff as well that there are
bigger questions too around workload and
that also needs addressing as a partner
i understand you don't want to cut
across blah blah but at the same time
what is the policy from labour what what
would be a reasonable pay rise for
teachers well if you look at our record
from government we delivered consistent
stable pay rises for teachers and for
support asking about the record i'm
asking about what would be your policy
you want to be the education secretary
what what would be a reasonable pay rise
for teachers well i think you do have to
judge us on our record if i were
education secretary i'll be working with
trade unions representing teachers and
support staff to make sure that they are
properly supported both in terms of pay
and in terms of workload that is also
why we've set out that we would end the
tax breaks private schools enjoy we
think that's completely wrong and out of
step and that we would put that money
into making sure that all of our
children in our brilliant state schools
get the best possible start in life okay
um just to uh quickly end by talking a
little bit about the concept of party
leadership election uh what candidate
would you be most worried about fighting
in a general election i'm not worried
about any of them i don't think we've
got anything to fear from any of the
candidates and the reason for that
is that all of them have propped up
boris johnson and the conservative
government for 12 years now and over
those 12 years what have we seen happen
in our country we've seen our vital
public services whether that's schools
or hospitals get worse and worse britain
is completely stuck you can't renew your
passport more and more people go into
food banks rising levels of child
poverty growth at a terrible level a
consistent failure to grow our economy
and what are they all doing an arms race
around tax cuts none of them prepared to
set out what that means how many
teachers how many doctors what will be
the impact on our public services they
should be asked those questions around
what that means and how they will
deliver it labor however we've been
clear that when we put forward any
policy we'll be clear about how we fund
it so today we are saying we are
reiterating our call for the government
to end those tax breaks that private
schools enjoy and to put that money into
state education will any of those
candidates make that commitment okay
thank you very much indeed uh bridget
phillips and there uh for the labour
party on the show today
well that is it for this week's uh
sophie ridge on sunday and actually it
is the end of the run as parliament is
breaking of course for the summer recess
next week it has been an absolutely
extraordinary roller coaster and i feel
like there's a few
loops to be at spun next week as well
remember of course that sky news
leadership debate hosted by kay burley
that'll be on tuesday so you don't want
to miss that plus of course at all those
voting rounds as well in the leadership
election starting again tomorrow don't
go anywhere because in a few moments
time i'm going to be joined by our
deputy political editor sam coats for
safety ridge on sunday the take thanks
for joining us this sunday morning
[Music]
the race is on the contestants who would
be the next prime minister are
finalizing their pitches the prize to
become the next leader of the
conservative party and grab the keys to
the most famous door in the world join
me kay burley as they go head to head
live
on sky news that's the battle for number
10 live on tuesday night at 8 on sky
news on our app online and our social
media channels
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie roach the
take where we take a moment and reflect
on what we've heard over the last hour
uh joined for a bit of analysis with our
deputy political editor sam uh coates uh
we can bring sam in uh now hello morning
and there's lots of chat was know about
the leadership election as you and i
have been talking about an awful lot
along with our colleagues over the last
week but it feels like we should
probably start with the heatwave doesn't
it because actually i do think that this
is what so many people are going to be
thinking about today uh we spoke to
dominic rather about it at the top and
he was pretty clear i thought wasn't he
about what his
stance is on
it yeah i i mean it's been a week
dominated by the conservative leadership
election for absolutely obvious reasons
but
government goes on because the
challenges don't go away and this is one
of the issues with a contest that's
going to keep going until september the
6th it is entirely unclear to me
that
people in government ministers are shall
we say doing the day job
properly and
we do have an unprecedented situation
we've got two days of potentially 40
degree plus
heatwave um we've got boris johnson at
checkers this weekend we understand
having a a sort of farewell party uh i
think that's taking place today
and we've got cobra meetings looking at
the heat emergency going on uh without
him uh so what was striking this morning
was that even the ministers that he did
have on seem to trigger a bit of
confusion about what to do in this heat
wave which is why it's worth listening
to a bit of dominick rahm
yeah hopefully we should be able to play
that clip of dominic raab today i asked
him about what should happen
for workplaces and also schools
we're coming to the end of uh
the the school term anyway but i think
making sure
young children
get the education they need is really
important particularly after the
pandemic
and the schools are well placed to deal
with that
yeah it's interesting there dominic rob
saying that it's up to employers whether
or not people should work from home or
not which it feels like it's
contradicting a little bit about what is
coming out from other ministers doesn't
understand
well that's exactly right so the
minister in charge of this uh is kit
matt morehouse he's uh taking over the
job of chancellor dutra of lancaster
which uh uh previously held uh by uh
boris johnson's chief of staff then
chief of staff steve barclay steve
buckley's now become the health
secretary it's a bit of a bit of a merry
go-round caused by the current political
crisis but kit mulhaus
basically gave uh made some public
remarks after holding that cobra meeting
yesterday to look at the emergency
and what he said
was that it's going to be very hard for
people to travel in this heat wave
so it may be a moment to work from home
but that wasn't what dominick robb said
dominick robb said to you it would be up
to employers to determine whether or not
their employees should work from home so
a pretty critical set of utterly mixed
messages i mean obviously dominic robert
is on your show
to talk about his uh backing of rishi
sunag but at the same time we have an
unprecedented situation he's the depth
prime minister you've got mixed messages
uh and that's only one of a number of
big challenges that will not wait for
the conservative party to break up their
mind he should be the next prime
minister you heard that uh with the
strikes that are approaching the summit
the decisions around pay awards um and a
whole host of other things uh and uh but
the country has to wait while the party
uh scratches it scratches its head and
make it makes up its mind yeah it feels
like that's a really important point uh
sam uh sam will have more from you in
just a moment just to introduce kind of
the next uh topic because it as someone
was saying it really does feel doesn't
it
as though
politics is almost being the day-to-day
running of the country when it comes to
politics is almost being put on hold
because we have this
all-consuming leadership uh battle and
of course uh whether it's writing rising
cases of covid whether it's the cost of
living whether it's the heatwave
politics doesn't always pause in that
way
that said we can turn now i think to the
kind of me to the programme which was
about the election of the next uh leader
most importantly of course the election
of the next prime minister as well so
the stakes really couldn't be higher and
there was a bit of an interesting
discussion around tax it does feel as if
the economics of the different
candidates is really come to the fore of
this election campaign
as well uh deputy prime minister dominic
raab is backing
rishi sunak the former chancellor for
the top job and let's have a little
listen to what he said about what mr
sunac's long-term plan for the economy
is
we want to all leave people with more
money in their pocket but if you cut
taxes and then inflation robs people of
that money because it's worthless or
sees interest rates go up so their
mortgages are more expensive then
frankly it's uh it's a it's a false
economy and i think rishi is the one
that is credibly stating until we
control inflation he's the only one
saying this we're not going to be able
to deliver those other things and he's
also the one that's talking about the
long-term plan to strengthen investment
by taking a different approach
regulatory wise he's talked about this
today tech pharmaceuticals
financial services areas of great
comparative advantage to the uk economy
so from the immediate challenge to the
long-term prospectus i think he's the
one with the plan liz trust says that
actually cutting taxes leads to growth
she said in the telegraph this morning
that a continuity economic policy under
who she could be talking about there has
led to low growth for decades
liz can answer for her policies and her
record she was chief secretary of the
treasury um people can see where the
spending and head count in the civil
service went up or down that's for them
to work out but what i just say this is
the immediate challenge what people are
worried about right now what do you mean
about the civil service
well
there's not just uh rishi that is going
to be accountable for what he's done in
the face of a massive pandemic but liz
has done was chief secretary of the
treasury i mean did she cut taxes at
that time did spending go up or down
during her period as uh cst i think
without without criticizing her
personally i think it's right that
everyone on their record is is
scrutinized
dominate rather really uh putting across
the rishi sunac position uh when it
comes to what the economic policy should
be in the years ahead and it does feel
like there's a real ideological battle
going on in the leadership race with
rishi sunak effectively saying that look
if you have unfunded tax cuts before
getting inflation over control that's
going to tank the economy the other
view on this is that proposed by liz
trust we spoke to uh syrian duncan smith
the former leader of the conservative
party supporter of liz smith his
argument and her argument is that
actually if you look at the only way to
try and boost growth you then in that
case that's when you need to actually
look at lower taxes in order to get the
economy in their view back on track
let's have a listen to what inducted
smith had to say
the treasury has the right to say no
between them and the bank frankly i
think they got that one wrong then the
second point is okay inflation is a big
problem because it takes away people's
earnings and their savings
and this is where liz is right about
this which is you now need to have to
look at two things though we have to get
inflation down and at last the bank is
raising interest rates and that should
begin to bring this under control but at
the same time if you end up
by trying to target that so exclusively
that you end up with the highest tax
rate that we've had since the 1940s you
will crush the economy at the same time
everybody's record should be fully open
and examined about your achievements
my point is we've had two and a half
years post-brexit where everybody bar
tom tugan hat i think is in government
everybody needs to be judged on what
they've achieved and that's the whole
campaign
and liz trust is open uh rishi sunak's
open kenny's open the one person i
personally don't know what her big
achievements are is penny i don't have
any problem with her no issues at all
but for me it's about
the key thing is we're not electing a
leader of the conservative party that
has two years to build their
their reputation we are electing someone
who will be prime minister on day one so
you need to know when they had power and
authority in government what did they do
with it what did they get what did they
achieve what were their main beliefs
what did they drive through what tough
decisions did they have to take that
actually they had to sometimes go
against their civil servants to get
these things done
they go in doug and smith there well it
feels like we kind of squashed two uh
points there from ending duncan smith so
we can try and like extract them shall
we and do them one in turn
if we can sam at first on the economic
situation and it does actually feel like
there's a genuine ideological battle
going on in the conservative party
leadership race about what to do with
tax cuts and what impact it's going to
have on the economy
yes and it it feels to me like it's
primarily a discussion by the two of the
biggest beasts in this contest uh rishi
sunak on one side and liz trust who he
and duncan smith was speaking for
on the other
but they disagree over the biggest
possible issues when it comes to how to
run the economy
they can't agree on for instance tax
cuts and whether or not effectively they
fund themselves because they cause uh so
much growth
they disagree on whether or not things
like tax cuts cause inflation they
disagree on how much of a priority
cutting borrowing should be that was of
course the number one goal in the 2015
conservative leadership election and
then they disagree uh on whether or not
essentially and this is what in duncan
smith was putting on the table uh at the
start of that section uh they disagree
on whether or not you could trust the
bank of england and the treasury as
institutions uh and so it just strikes
me sophie that
uh you are choosing between two very
very different paths for the united
kingdom in this leadership contest
and in many ways although
the country and the government is in
stasis until september the 6th
also elements of this race are taking
place incredibly quickly given the scale
of the policy choices and the arguments
that people are going to get to grips
with decide whether they believe uh that
are there at heart because one path uh
we'll see higher borrowing lower taxes
uh earlier on and frankly a huge amount
of criticism on what's known as monetary
policy uh that bit of policy that's
decided by the bank of england uh and uh
while the other at slight more status
quo former chancellor rishi sunak
will keep borrowing slightly lower push
tax cuts off a little bit further
and um defend the record of both the
bank of england and the treasury um and
those takes us to two very different
places uh the gap couldn't be bigger the
chasm within the conservative party
couldn't be put couldn't be bigger and
that does just make it feel uh that it's
gonna be harder for the conservative
party to as it were heal after this
leadership contest because clearly
people totally disagree uh on what they
should be doing when it comes uh to
handling uh the economy um but it also
just in the narrow terms of this
leadership contest does mean we have two
of the five candidates who are seen to
be dominating the economic uh arguments
uh whereas the others uh i'm afraid to
say are at the moment a bit more like
bit players on this specific issue i
think that's exactly it it's um
like you say it's it's actually quite
extraordinary at how polarized the
debate is and how important the choices
are ahead of for the mps and then the
members choosing of course the next
prime minister um i think sam was
touching quite an important point there
and we'll go back to sam uh in a moment
and about the tone of the debate too
because what you're seeing is with these
two big ideological differences in terms
of the economy
the others side are effectively trashing
the other arguments so in doug and smith
saying look if you follow the russia
soon net path and that is going to lead
to low growth and we're going to be in a
huge problem there and of course and
then you have dominic rabb saying look
if you look at liz trust and the others
in the race and this is effectively you
know fantasy uh politics and we did hear
in duck and smith talking a bit there
about penny morden and which i think we
should talk about after the break
actually because there's another quite
important point to make there about the
tone of the debate and some of the
attacks that we're starting to see on
the candidates so more in just a moment
[Music]
it's an epic life yeah it is much bigger
than the story of a singer-songwriter
it's the it's the story of a man who
reflected history changed history it's
the story about being gay in the music
industry in the 1980s and 90s which was
another world entirely than what the one
that we know today when that is an asset
in george's day it was not he did not
like what he saw in the mirror from his
childhood george had begun feeling bad
about himself he had a very tough greek
cypriot immigrant father to north london
who was this intimidating self-made man
who had very traditional
views on what constituted a man what
constituted a woman and george
uh saw a pimply nerd in the mirror and
and at the time he was that and then of
course he met andrew ridgely and wham
happened and in andrew he saw the
template for what he could possibly be i
saw him in his uh 25 live tour which you
remember his greatest hits tour of 2006
7-8 which was a huge worldwide success
but it was a greatest hit store and in
the u.s he was by that time perceived as
an oldies act i think that when you feel
bad about yourself when you don't
respect yourself when you don't think
that you're beautiful then it doesn't
matter how many millions of people are
screaming for you because you will not
believe them and the loss of anselmo
followed by the loss of his beautiful
mother leslie who died prematurely of
cancer within the space of four years
uh this pulled the carpet out from
underneath george michael and he really
began a downward spiral that just got
worse and worse
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the boat
well just a couple of days time of
course until we do find out who are
going to be the two names on the ballot
for the conservative party members to
decide on the next prime minister and it
feels like it has been a campaign on
fast forward there's been as we were
just discussing with sam so many big
ideological questions but also quite a
lot of personal
attacks as well
lots of uh little digs shall we say at
some of the candidates we heard a few
concerns from ian duncan smith about
penny maldon who he said was untested
ahead of the break uh let's bring sam
back in shall we some coats um
to discuss that and they just can't help
themselves can we
ian duncan smith talking about at penny
morden earlier on in the programme
dominic ra was talking about liz truss's
record in government as well
it does certainly feel
as if you know the knives really are out
that's right i mean let's on one level i
i feel like so we ought not to be naive
about this this is a leadership contest
where personality character background
is as important as policy position but i
do think there's something a bit unusual
about this contest which is because of
the time of year that it's happened in
this process of whittling down the mps
who are going to stand who are going to
go to the conservative party members in
the country has been
shortened dramatically um and that means
that the conservative party is having to
do at breakneck speed make very big
decisions about essentially about
people's characters and i think that's
one of the things that's making
some of the discussion more robust some
of the more discussion more unpleasant
and over the sort of my god it's only
been
what is it nine days since boris johnson
resigned but over that period it's
really been two phases of the
conversation the first uh for about the
first seven days there were relentless
attacks particularly from some of those
uh backing liz trust against rishi sunak
he was being accused of undermining and
ultimately uh defenestrating rishi uh uh
boris johnson uh he was accused of being
prepared to spend too much much not cut
enough taxes and every day in certain
newspapers and from certain members of
the party he was getting the lion's
share of the hammering and then all of a
sudden particularly after that yougov
poll that we uh broke on air earlier
this week sophie penny morden emerged as
the front runner at which point the
attacks again largely it seems in many
ways from the liz trust camp switched
over to penny mordent now what's
interesting about her is that she is
much less well known she has had cabinet
jobs two of them
international
development and defense secretary
but suddenly large numbers of party
establishment people were picking on her
going through her book going through her
record as a qualities uh minister
questioning uh her position on whether
or not she backed uh making it easier uh
to uh change uh gender uh and those are
some of the attacks that you're seeing
in the papers at the moment kemi
badenock uh is um has in fact frankly
benefited from quite a lot of this uh
because um she is uh less well-known she
is uh more in favor of the right but she
too uh uh is essentially a clean slate
in the views of many uh mps not mind
members so when it comes to personality
and when it comes to bluntly to policy
she start having to start out afresh
tell people what she's about and that's
frankly why we heard quite a lot from
lee rowley uh her campaign manager about
exactly what she was going to do sing
isn't it sam and i'm quite keen to get
your take on this if you like because as
you were saying it feels like the
attacks are effectively following the
ebb and flow or the leadership campaign
who is up who's down who the polling
seems to suggest could make the final
two and it is quite fluid situation
um after the first debate it feels like
this morning there is an awful lot of
talk about kemi bajenlok and her
candidacy there's a conservative home
poll that puts her as the most popular
although unweighted it's important to
say
um
many people will have never heard of her
before this contest started is she a
serious contender to make the final two
or do you think that realistically
she's had a good campaign but she's not
gonna you know be really in the running
for the big job
i think her team absolutely insists that
she's serious it is quite hard for
somebody who has never had cabinet
experience as tom tugan had in this race
also hasn't uh to get uh basically to
pulvel from a minister of state job uh
into number ten uh she's at the
beginning of a journey of setting out uh
how she would do that
but there were only 36 hours 48 hours 72
hours uh until tory mps decides uh the
final two and i wonder whether or not if
this contest was two or three weeks or
this bit of the contest rather was two
or three or three weeks longer whether
or not she would have a greater chance
but she is just that little bit further
behind when it comes to mps uh and it's
not clear that she will pole vault into
the final two
but given the conservative party is
relentlessly attacking uh the top three
candidates particularly uh penny morden
there's always a chance that suddenly
that could be a big switch we've got one
more debate tonight we've got another uh
debate
on sky news on tuesday there is movement
between the mps anything could happen
but uh it's
[Music]
[Applause]
organized
[Music]
this is sky news at 10 the headlines the
race for number 10 heats up as the
candidates prepare for their second tv
debate for the economy taking center
stage in the battles to replace boris
johnson
luke liz can answer for her policies and
her record she was chief secretary